on va faire la meilleure offre et il m'a
inspiré pour créer un jeu dans lequel on
va s'affronter tous les deux dans les
crocs pour apparaître deux offres une
offre visible et une offre mystère ces
offres sont des défis on va devoir
relever tous les deux à toi de choisir
en premier ce tu veux l'offre vizille où
l'offre mystère moi je ferais l'autre
quoi qu'il arrive c'est l'offre visible
peut être pire que l'offre mystère amis
ou inversement
voici la première offre que je te fais
mon jus gars se casser un oeuf pourri
sur la tête par des choses je voyais ça
après je suis venu j'ai vu ça je suis
parti et je reviens il ya eu alors se
casser un oeuf pourri sur la tête ça
veut dire que c'est toi qu'il fait si je
prends ce qu'il ya dans le sang c'est
moi qui le fais je prends de la surprise
tu prends la surprise je suis sûr que
c'est pire mais j'ai quand même un
progrès parce que je vais le faire comme
ça au moins ce sera fait merci le
problème c'est que la différence entre
violence et toi ça te fait plaisir dans
les essais des oeufs sur la lune tu vois
tu le fais voilà pour les joueurs mais
c'est mauvais pour la connerie julia on
va voir tout de suite qu'elle était
l'autre offre s'il vous plaît se faire
casser
[Applaudissements]
c'est au début d'émission ça serait la
femme si tu restes
c'est quoi tu le feras la fin ça à
l'attrait quoi lâcher d'accord je suis
d'accord la fois deux fois et je sais
qu'il tiendra sa promesse voilà c'est
l'invité 2009 retail enfin la frappe
attention il le fera avant de partir
vous inquiétez pas c'est moi même qui
lui casser les os se faire épiler une
part de record cg à ce propos il ya
quelques temps on est encore au studio
là bas tu m'as épiler ah oui le bas ici
et ce n'a jamais rien ici ne s'est
jamais fait c'est vachement bien mais
nous on va se figer des pôles qui
démarre à 30 centimes alors quelle
partie du corps ce jeu choisir ce
qu'elle fait de l'autre côté de l'agent
mais je choisis la partie et que tu vas
faire le sillon un terreau fessiers ou
un truc comme ça j'ai vu tout à l'heure
c'était pire clamé en foutent bien
valable l'offre était pire tout à
l'heure donc là justement où je dois
aller jour où l'eau sur l'autre aulas
alors moi donc je me ferais connu deux
parties une partie du corps a mené on
peut faire parce que vous le faire
serrer le jeu ouais bah oui c'est vrai
quel parti à mener pour vous le fait
aussi rêver
[Rires]
non mais vous les gens me sert beaucoup
plus voilà les temps qui courent aussi
on va se voir le bras est pris dans la
formule voilà merci au fond il attendait
votre banque vous étiez cette chaîne
vraiment ouais ça m'est arrivé
qu'est-ce qu'il faut retirer dans le
sens du poil
donc alors pu faire du pois chiche à
tous de faire là bas on est obligé passe
comme ça alors si vous avez maintenant
on va avoir mal juste mettre votre
présence nous préfère bouder d'avoir mal
le pauvre et en tirant par rapport à
juger rien all over
[Rires]
je garde tout chez moi qu'il ya des faux
culs diakhou ba ouais merci on va voir
ce qu'il y avait pour julien courbet
julien courbet du salut au cul au
téléphone à bourges à la la la
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que je peux choisir le dirigerait
oui tu peux je donne le numéro ok ils
ont vous avez des numéros précise de
nous écouter je soutiens je mets l'eau
par la royal oak e géré dieu fait répit
les barrages auraient pu faire le
dirigeant de m6 allez on y va du coup je
reviens à votre proposition de peut-être
me rapprocher de ses huit assez rapide
tu sais qui c'est à dire du racé qui a
pressé que m c'est bien que je connais
c'est qui curiel jonathan qu il appelle
un groupe à trondheim si c'est nathan
way jonathan je suis désolé mais je sais
pas si tu cours tu l'as vu mon cul
[Applaudissements]
et dessous
si je pense à des collabos démission je
tombais nous pensons même s'il te parle
je l'attends merci ou des franches mais
il est désolé c'est pas la faute de
julien voilà c'était mon sens prennent
tous les jours sur m6
je vous en droit john a tort d'accord
j'ai un atelier très sympa mais
attention c'est le directeur de provale
de 6,1 de tous les magazines c'est un
vrai françois donc il nous a pas
rappelés du lourd
c'est pas mal j'aime bien j'aime bien
j'aime bien c'est quoi la prochaine
c'est quoi la prochaine
j'ai une cuillère de cacao tout garder
sa main dans un bocal rempli dans cette
vision c'est bien ça je le fais ok
j'aime pas ça tu préfères par sa wii
voici sept fait plaisir moi on est là
pour s'amuser à amener les insectes
donc on va voir ce que je vais faire
après mois la marque apparemment ben je
sais pas ça va être pire on voit bien
qu'il ya un secteur sans excuse moi je
sais qu'on étende émission sais rien à
droite rendant 500 comptes un prénom
elle s'est récemment vinci attend des
entretiens avec le bocal au dessus bras
tu fais comme ça tout ça mais là ça n'a
l'air de rien j'ai touché jours de ça
salut
[Applaudissements]
castaldi l'a été dans le bocal alors et
et moi et moi ça va faire quoi
c'est quoi un raisin meilleure offre
c'est quoi moi bah c'était manger des
insectes
je n'aime pas j'aime pavanant est le
bras il est bien faire céder un shérif
les plus regardés à la mc2 idée un
talent et c'est tout le vin quel goût ça
vous a pas de goût ouais c'est vrai vous
êtes courageuse tabac c'est dur à avaler
c'est bon shirin la joie à mâcher de
boutade l'attaquant cyril aussi dorée
veut pas me lâcher s'intaller le derby à
mai dernier donc c'est instaurer cottard
ça démarre fort et mokhtar n'étant pas
là non oktar n'étant pas là ce sera ce
sera ce sera
on tient ce soir mais mon attention moi
je t'aime beaucoup je t'écoute le matin
je vais prendre le sloan et crémants
[Applaudissements]
à temps
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est quoi c'est quoi mais de quoi tu
sais quoi
s'il vous plaît s'il est choisi il
choisit la politique
[Applaudissements]
et
hop hop